hello and welcome to New World review
where we take your favorite mangas and
animes and turn them into your worst
nightmare that's right I'll take the
sense of victory you feel at managing to
pass that exam and turn it into
literally a burning husk of sadness at
the finish line of horror leaving you
unsmiling it alone like Hisoka at a
baseball match it's me brand line waifu
ready to give you a review of episodes
12 and 14 Queens I have been advised
that episode 13 is a recap episode so
while I may watch it for my benefit I
think it would be boring for you to hear
me review twelve episodes of previous
content as one new episode but hey for
those who don't like me only reviewing
two episodes at a time because of how
long it will take to finish this series
that means there are only a hundred and
thirty three episodes worth of review to
go also I'm bad at math so if that's
incorrect I mean me thank you for the
feedback you gave give and will give I
really appreciate it all if you're
enjoying what you're seeing hearing
smelling touching and tasting please hit
that happy happy joy joy album if not
hit that miserable down thumb now on
with the episode there will be spoilers
many this is a review expect ex Boyle
export no hang on episode 12 was not as
much montage as I was expecting it to be
the audio is consistent comic relief was
on display and I'm starting to wonder
whether he has some serious blood
pressure issues it was great for us to
see his thought processes the strain of
knowing he'd messed up and the guilt of
ruining things for others was good but
we didn't go far enough into it and
because nothing came of it I was left
hoping it'll set something up for the
future rather than being a bit of philic
thought content now that's it I feel
like the series overall has so far come
through on thought processes that gets
set up and knocked down but we'll come
back to the gone and hisoka's love story
in a bit I realize now that a focus of
the episode was on the relationships
that are building between very specific
characters first up we've got the
relationship between Gahan and kill WA
which is that of a couple of kids having
a great time except one of them is an
assassin the other an innocent sociopath
their bond is growing and I appreciate
and respect it it's fine everything's
fine and he'll work out just fine it's
not fine it's becoming more and more
clear that as the numbers of the exam
draw
competition is going to become a serious
concern that said I may well have missed
some information but I don't think we've
been told yet how many can pass the exam
so it's entirely possible that this
competition is something they could
fight for right to the end speaking of
fighting right to the end Tonpa had a
180 degree change of heart this episode
up until now he hasn't trusted anyone
and every reflective moment has been
about showing how much trickery he can
pull to ruin other examinees chances I
don't know if it's a 180 or that he's
never actually had people force him into
a lie ship but there was something very
particular about the way he mentally
responded to lis audio saying that the
lack of trust between the audio and tone
/ is mutual suggests a couple of things
given it was in his mind it suggests to
me that he somewhat trusts the rest of
the party it also suggests that he's
slowly coming to feel as though he is
part of the group
despite deciding to attack the audio at
the final hurdle but that's the point I
suppose isn't it he decides to attack
the audio very specifically does Tompa
feel that if he got rid of lis audio he
could take lis audio his place in the
group and potentially finish the exam we
don't get any further insight really
into tone / beyond that but the
similarity between the two is very
clearly shown in their socks t9 they are
well-balanced opponents one a healer one
a poisoner to return to episode 2 if
Tompa wanted he could probably be a
decent healer
he has the insight required to be a good
guy the ability to read situations the
others don't and he seems at this point
to be beginning to find the antics of
our main characters somewhat endearing
on that point I did stop to consider the
title of the episode the last test of
resolve whose resolve is being tested in
this episode arguably tompa's which is
so annoying for me as someone who
repeatedly tried to dismiss him I don't
get it right every time I guess it's
very clear and everyone in that tiny
space at the end knows if Kilwa wants
gone to get to the end of the exam kilwa
and gan will get to the end of the exam
that's not a test of resolve it's a fact
and everyone just dismisses Korra pika
he's like that person who manages to fly
under the radar in every season of Big
Brother just to sneak up and win at the
end I was honestly a little surprised
when lei audio didn't sacrifice himself
out of guilt because I thought that's
what we've been building toward with
Tompa for the last two episodes I guess
we'll just keep building that guilt
until it ferments into something else or
fizzles out now before I forget you
sokka and gone that tiny smile of his
focus that came from gone and the others
stepping out and completing the exam was
so beautifully subtle it showed his
sokka's investment in gone in the party
it showed exactly who he was waiting for
and watching for every time a door
opened the small Nick to his clothes the
small wound he took a few episodes ago
is almost a metaphor for the opening
we're seeing into his personality in
true cell despite being a self isolating
character he very much seems to enjoy
and want to enjoy the company of his
competition he doesn't want to be
friends with gone or maybe he does but
in a competitive manner no one else who
walks out gets that tiny response from
his soca which tells me that there is
only one other person he respects in
this exam basically Hisoka has an
ability crush on gone which gone of
course will be able to leverage later in
the exam I can't wait to see how it
plays out before we move on to episode
14 I just have to say pincushion guy
what the actual what is that eating
method he's like a rabbit or a squirrel
it reminds me of me eating wafers when I
was six after watching my babysitter's
rabbit eat carrots
whenever I worry that I'm weird I can
think back to that guy nomming or
whatever it was he Nam
it was weird episode 14 ok so this
episode was very hit and miss for me pun
intended and I think it confused me more
than I'd like to admit
basically child enters hunter exam child
progresses to 4th phase of hunter exam
child realizes at 4th phase that it's
necessary to hunt in order to pass
hunter exam child forgets that hunting
also means being hunted hunter squared
we're whittling down the examinees
hunter bye hunter I think I've cracked
the title of a show now in the same way
that God has finally cracked the entire
purpose of the exam about time I
supposed to be firm episode 12 was all
about testing the resolve of the
examinees seeing whether they really
wanted what they were there for and
testing whether they could stand up to
the challenges put forth the first phase
tested their physical stamina the second
their sense of risk-taking the third
their resolve and the fourth their
actual ability to hunt it makes sense I
suppose if you look at it that way and
this would be the phase that gone is the
least equipped to deal with if I were
that guy in the bushes though I'd have
already taken God's tag while he was
sleeping out in the
open on his back I mean maybe Gahan was
smart enough to hide it somewhere away
from him but it seemed so odd for the
other hunter to just watch and wait when
the child was literally asleep it's
almost like he didn't want to win or
maybe it's a case of being so cocky he
wants to see whether the kid gets better
before trying to take the win away from
him anyway this episode was very much
about gone learning to hunt going
through the motions it's somewhat
worried and surprised me that he didn't
have a concept of hunting before what
did he think hunters did why did he
think they did what they did how did he
think they got what they wanted or what
they got I think the thing I'm
struggling with is that this highly
perceptive sociopathic kid didn't know
how to hunt every step of this exam
makes him more dangerous honing his
skills which is the point right you
either learn quickly during the exam or
you fail it but he really should have
known that he's a hunter and the aim is
to become a hunter and the aim is to
know how to hunt
that's odd to me oh another thing that's
interesting to look at the use of time
episode 12 is all about wasting time
about having too much and nothing to do
time was wasted when we look back and in
the context of that episode 2 we
realized Gahan is used to baiting and
catching characters but only static or
easy ones this episode is his level up
montage where he diversifies his skills
he knows he can't win in direct combat
but our little sociopath is excited by
the idea of going up against his
greatest competitor he's crazy I don't
honestly know how it's going to go but
I'm very interested to see whether Gahan
tries and fails but Hisoka just gives
him the tag because his oak is enamored
with him or if he'll actually manage to
get it at this point it's probably fair
to say that Gahan Lee Oreo karateka and
Kilwa have some plot armor since they're
heavily featured in the credits sequence
but also because everything we've done
has focused on them
I'd also however argue that Hisoka has
the same plot armor so it'll be exciting
to see how this is resolved since I have
no doubt Hisoka will get through this
phase this is the phase I would expect
his Sokka to be naturally strong at in
an odd possibly concerning way I feel
kinship with his Sokka if I were him I
would probably chill until maybe four
days into the exam and simply go around
killing and knocking out people who have
collected tags from others it wouldn't
be so difficult to do not as Hisoka then
again to combat that mentality as a
hunter I would also hide my collected
so that even if someone tried to hit me
up they'd get nothing and I think that's
an important thing for me at this point
because this is the first time I've
actually taken a direct interest in how
I would pass the exam myself
besides alluding to possible ways
through the last phase here episode 14
to me is the crux of being a hunter it's
what I think of if someone says hunter
exam the rest didn't need deep thought
or consideration I guess it was the
simplest of actions survive run the
climb breathe focus fight all those
things have finally built to this phase
and that is a nice preparation for the
next because if the players can prove
their ability to hunt in this way what's
the next phase what is there left to
test finally I feel curiosity about the
hunter exam and it only took 14 episodes
of exam content for me to care about how
the exam is affecting the characters and
how the content is itself developing
it's been a long long road but we're
finally here I guess to a certain degree
this is the point at which I have
leveled up as well
I know enough about these primary
characters to be able to anticipate to
some degree their behaviors to
understand their backstories to
experience their strengths and failures
and see them grow the gone we
encountered in Episode one is not the
gone we encounter now didn't lay audio
we met in Episode one is also not the
same as the one we know now karapa car
has not changed at all on the outside
though I wonder how much has changed on
the inside since Kiowas question about
whether he is afraid to kill it was a
small question but one that I'm hoping
comes back we can see that his soca
isn't perfect and that Gaughan has
noticed this the tears in his clothes
got a nice shot indicating basic
learning that he is fallible Kilwa has
changed though we didn't see what he was
before not properly now we know that he
cares about gone and we'll see how that
develops I sent by coming to the end of
an arc and it's got a nice sense of
completeness overall I'm glad I've stuck
around to watch this far it was touch
and go with some of the earlier ones but
let's see where this ride goes for now
that's it for me if you enjoyed this
video and the content this channel
produces in general please do consider
donating to the new world review patreon
because the support of all you amazing
people is what continues to make this
channel possible if patreon isn't quite
style and please do leave this video a
like share or subscribe because it also
helps support the channel an incredible
amount and if you'd like to join the fun
then please do head over to the discord
server where a wide array of shenanigan
retakes place on a daily basis and
finally please do comment with your
thoughts on episodes 12 and 13 of Hunter
hunter this has been the New World
review and I'll see you next
[Music]